peu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui les collants stick vous
dit rien parce que je passe à deux
scandales mais alors quels pots de colle
il fait des idées ou quoi j'ai accepté
cette série de ce lot avec lui pour pas
faire tapisserie devant les copines mais
alors j'en voit plus le bout
mine de rien je suis en train d'emballer
mois jean valjean balcik allez vas-y
celle aux attaques
altec ça marche ça m'a gêné
la nuit est à nous
[Musique]
ça n'en finit pas qu'est ce que je
regrette d'avoir dit oui à ce type en
plus il s'est aspergé d'eau toilette mon
dieu je sais pas ce que c'est que cette
aux toilettes mais alors thomas
commodore elle est pas mal moins qu à
venir est pas terrible deuil mais pas mr
une fois gympie a été de la plus moche
y'a pas longtemps je me suis coltiné une
géante toute la soirée - c'est là et
elle m'a taillé une beauté rime mais
bataille pas du tout mon géant garçons
moi j'aime le grand blond alors je suis
servi comme était qu on fait pas mieux
je suis sûr qu'il doit avec libanais aux
quelque chose quelle horreur bon et puis
alors il donne chaud a reconnu comme ça
il m'a dit que je te colle et vas-y que
je te pas
oh dommage qu'elle ait les mains moites
ça me gêne pas des masses mais elle a
les mêmes mouettes
c'est parce que je dois lui faire de
l'effet
l'excitation je vais lui mordiller lobe
de l'oreille
s'ils ne font pas une baffe si j'ai ma
chance
ouais c'est pas dans la poche
faut s'accrocher accroche-toi génome il
m'a mordu l'oreille m'a fait mal ce
qu'on est con ce type en valeur de ce
truc copains c'est tout voile est
nauséabonde tuera les copines qui me
regarde comment que je te le peintre est
là mais ça arlette et josy je veux pas
la face ce plaisir l oms sont vertes de
mouvoir dans ces malades d'orage alors
ça maintenant plus chez eux au bout mais
alors on peut dire j'aime coutin et là
on peut plus hilarant 20 la courte et
encore j'ai pas sortir un jeu attend un
peu que je me des chaînes
allez vas-y
dijon
et
[Musique]
bien de vomi
la dernière fois que je viens danser
tant pis si je croise anne-catherine m'a
alors les excités comme ça merci bien
je vais lui terrifié le dos avec mon
pouce
il paraît qu'ils adorent ça à ses
chiennes jamais lu dans une revue
spécialisée
parce que c'est là
je vais partir
remonté jusqu'à la nec
il est givre a sonné
il m a labouré roi du doubs avec son
ongle par un plaisir braqué à malefoy
cicatriser c'est bien ma veine il a
fallu que je tombe sur un sadique tout
moi ça me mom ça finisse gelot parce que
je suis au bord de l'esclandre bien
jouer jaloux elle est à point là elle
est à point
y'a plus qu'à porter l'estocade allez
vas-y janot plazy monfils
pour conclure maintenant berck
et voilà le pareil c'est pas si
compliqué les gonzesses
savoir s'est imposée c'est tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chic et chic et oui m'énerve un peu
prétentieux qu'elles prêtent anxieux
mais pour qui france et espagne a jamais
bonjour mais qui consomme trois fois
j'ai pas mal ficelé t-il vedette de
l'établissement oui madame si brillante
et matériels saison à clermont clément
mais je ne crois pas au moment de votre
fiche mais c'est très simple c'est parce
qu'ils ont passé deux fois non et
allemands alors que lieu l'espagne où il
est venu
bon ça moi aussi je n'ai pas vu que chez
moi ça tellement thématiques qui fait
mieux que lui
un suédois après la célébration à deux
minutes je ne la lecture mais alors là
ça va changer
hans jörg butt 10e jour soit sa
provenance de l'élite mais lui je le pas
n'est toujours pas bien si par malheur
il ya trois pierres fobis alors là on
n'arrête plus la fermeture est trop lu
les faits la clé
il
chicken inertie chichi qui regardaient
le s'est énervé et je te calmes aussi le
savez quoi il a cassé son talent on a
loupé à l'espace est monté à la tête
il a fait comme si de rien n'était c'est
aux habits la termine en chaussettes
fera bouger
on nous a dit qu'il nous narguer savez
sont tellement fiers
maintenant tous aussi pierre moureu déjà
tous en même temps français
leur horizon j'aurais mangé une base de
données de recherche avait la figure
comme un fait accompli
alors la corrida bon je pèse quoi nous
nous attendions adresse par l'entrée
panet plein
et je me tourne amour c'est comme le
camp d'obèse ça va être un beau
prétentieux silence radio en plein les
mains se dit pas bonjour
mais on aime bon sort
oui
binoche et l'explosif à levie garder
l'enfant joue et danse à la pâte et 6 2
[Applaudissements]
marrakech
ça nous a dit sue là nous a pas plu
c'est plein d'à pourtant dans ce nom à
la ville vers clichy et la lionne à des
arabes à mai à marrakech
y'a que ça non déjà à l'avion pour y
aller ça nous avait pas fait bonne
impression
c'est plate à l'acquisition d'avions
c'est l'avion comme lionel nallet un
congrès de l'entreprise il avait plutôt
bien fait les chérissait
un petit avion ring pour nous les
collègues de l'entreprise bien aucune
promiscuité bien mais c'est quand on a
vu arriver l'aviateur ou quel malheur
vous savez pas qu'est-ce qui vous avez
trouvé comme agathe heures anna et je
dis à ma moitié ça commence bien
ma pauvre simone d'un couac on sait
encore embarqué qu'est l'eau et l'autre
à la rate plus à l'aise pas gêné du tout
du tout - arabe
je ne sois diffusion tout petits dés
fois qu'on marque pas et je veux c'est
géraud de passe doit s'établir et je
veux pas vad
c'est moi que je suis le maître à bord
visible peut légalement mais je tripote
les manettes les petits boutons comme si
j'aurais fait ça depuis toujours comme
si damazin s'être personne n'aurait
jamais gardé une chèvre deux familles
ils ont pris acte hulot avec les
collègues on veut pas on est des
touristes
le corps d'un civil moulay ahmed
benyahia ouled nous souhaite la
bienvenue à bord très bien parfait c'est
pas le faire des remarques l'armée
française avec à personne car ayem ce
cas grec était à côté avoir comme avec
le service meilleur qu'en dise
d'hôtesses et de bonbons evologia une
gamme d olive des cacahuètes
l'habitant de mechtras n'attendent
qu'une chose de pas catholique à
l'attaqué en question
15 08 ceinture d'ailleurs c'est local
aviator arabe lui même qui nous a
demandé d attacher il ce qu'elle tombe
mesdames je lui suis vous êtes priés
d'attaché vos ceintures et des tonnes de
cigarettes en quarts grâce à ses passes
il a senti d'insta par une sourde
oreille probation ou quoi n'empêche que
blanc de tout le voyage les s6 dames
n'ont pas ces sites se multiplient
mais ce cadeau mais vite la rénine omar
volontairement commence d'exacerber déjà
les îles hockey est ce que quelqu'un
parmi les passagers qui pourraient me
passer un big palace à la fin que je
fasse mes calculs sinon on peut pas
décoller ça fait sérieux
moi j'avais mon waterman à plumes
incorporé plaqué or que simone m'a
offert pour ma nomination à la direction
du service réclamation de la meilleure
c'est que ces gens-là ne décrivent pas
du tout comme nous autres on sait que
lui décline de droite à gauche
votre moitié rhmani vous rendre
complètement les saloperies comme si
vous leur âme quand il vole pas haut
comme le prétend après que soi disant
ils auraient été égarés et waterman
mais la plus belle course aux cadeaux
qui volent oui mais oui ben voyons
l'école et moi c'est sous la selle ce
cador est ici dit oui à passer chose qui
le minent
et nous avons plus de jeunes me les
métaux le seigneur soit erreurs pendant
toute la traversée il a pas arrêté de se
faire remarquer un moment c'était un peu
assoupie avec les collègues méninges
chaleur qui réunit la carlingue et les
nerfs qui commençait sur la chaîne mon
amie on est tous réveillés en sursaut
c'était encore lui lot l'indigène qui
criait sans se retourner à genève où ça
sent le brûlé
tout ça en repli comme des cockers dans
la travée
dit ou pas assez cadré il s'amuse avec
nous quoi j'adorais très fin psychologue
me dit il s'amuse très bien parfait
amusons-nous où la france est à quatre
pattes est tout à fait dans le sens de
l'histoire
le maréchal lyautey et moi nous nous
inclinons et juste après il se met à
hurler dans son micro comme un
hystérique
alors à tous les contrats longs la
technique au sol pour les mondiaux rouge
maintenant sur plus je n'en ai pas la
moindre idée d'installer tisseur de
consulter au bord de tous les deux la
mienne lasimant était pas non plus très
de l'avoir hammadides - des coups jeudi
bouge pas six mois ne bouge pas de petit
match et là comme polis 15 poussins quel
terminal six avions tendance est de dix
ans de leur tarde à l'infini passé
pourrait déjà quelque chose là partout
des arabes des arabes
déjà que ça que sa caisse à les porter
ah bon ça normal
les douaniers à des policiers a même
droit wallabies fois en réalité ce
serait une très correctement la famille
nationale ou leigh qui sont chez eux
encore lui le roi l'autre là le roi il
est pas mal de gars sont ils pas mal
attachés il obtient la dragée haute à
tous ces va nu pieds je me demande si ap
un peu de safran c'est ce mot là quoi
qu'il en soit jeudi à simone c'est la
dernière fois qu'on met les pieds en
colonie il faut pas me dire raciste
c'est à nous dans l'entreprise nous
employons énormément de travail on north
africa et bien nous les avons laissé
installer leur village leur espèce
depuis dans tout chantier
le forum des poules de pouvoir de la
maison monsieur bourdieu qui est un
homme très libéral pedro à gauche
arrivait un jour au bureau complètement
retourné en usage de patients voiture
fait des baraques ont leurs africains il
faut absolument faire quelque chose pour
ces malheureux nous pourrons pas tenir
une paris misère
en plus ça se voit de la route est
fâcheux pour le standing de la maison eh
bien nous nous sommes réunis en comité
nous avons voté des crédits pour les
mois vous pouvez passer en voiture près
de chez nous vous verrez plus rien de
tout ça ils ont fait construire un mur
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'elles sont belles ces nanas
à la vache tels sont belles à les salles
en salles aux pays bas son téléphone sur
la photo s'est fait comme ça des frais
pour venir l'aider à briser son logis
est drôlement usagers semblent logis là
je vais pas critiquer mais c'est pas une
première massa [ __ ]
non là c'est servan-schreiber
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il fout là jusqu'au bout et
jss jusqu'au bout il ya quand même pesté
lequel j'y étais sinon ce serait
chouette comme argument électoral
radical souhaite tous les gus qui
viennent avait filé les dessous de la
politique par jacques chirac giscard
d'estaing d'un soufflé mon petit
accordéon jour une surprise mais ainsi
de suite et c'est ça serai pas triste
ça serait peut être
jusqu'au bout a exigé c'est sûr dit
quand même j'aime mieux aller jusqu'où
avec ma copine au blue jeans où elle est
ma copine
voilà aulas elle a égaré son panty ok
c'est qu'il a pu ça c'est chouette c'est
futé ceux qui font ça le magazine de
l'homme moderne
ces députés ils sont futés il mélange
tout jjss nadia l'aris chat
jean paul sartre zaza sème la zizanie
c'est futé 1
ça m'arrange pour amener de la lecture à
la maison un chouette parce que les
filles les vraies celles qu'on peut
toucher mon kiwi tous conquis quand
c'est transparent mini jupe mini short
blanche la louche adobe a été présentée
police comme avant
l'or qui mène à la tête sont encore en
clean line certaine
[Applaudissements]
les ce qui reste
questionné femme josette ne pas prendre
la pilule pour garder la ligne tout est
tellement défendue par les grossesses
est entre deux accouchements ou même
plus la différence
il faut lutter contre l'assouplissement
sexuelle imany le docteur je lui dis
docteur je lui à la fin j'ai pas eu
celle la salle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hier soir au palais des sports
un jeune boxeur battu par ko au premier
round a peut-être vu s'envoler sa
dernière chance de devenir un grand
champion
nous sommes allés lui poser quelques
questions alors ça va un peu mieux
oui aujourd'hui ça va mieux j'ai fait
des compresses
c'est ma femme qui m'a soignée elle a dû
être déçu votre femme elle a été
surprise elle matin des petits bonheurs
on peut dire que ça a été rapide
le combat a duré combien de temps
exactement deux minutes neuf secondes
enfin côté 10 secondes pour le chaos je
pose mon 9 je retiens ça fait une minute
59 deux côtés on est plus vite rentrer
chez soi parce que traîner sur un ring
et puis au vestiaire et au bistrot c'est
pas une solution non plus surtout pour
les sportifs
que pensez vous de votre adversaire un
type très antipathique tout de suite et
m'a déplu des enjeux les 10èmes siramy
respirait mieux c'est mon manager je lui
dois tout tu lui qui m'a trouvé mon
surnom puis djibil comment mais non moi
je m'appelle maurice c'est comme johnny
hallyday et sa veulent pas de journée à
lille et je le sais je les lis beaucoup
thank you ramires qui m'a fait découvrir
la lecture tu dois tout la boxe la
culture puis jean bill et assoit y aller
mal élevés qui m'ont appelé penjing
balle s'ils croient me démoraliser
j'aurais mieux aimé des mois
l'opinion du vaincu sur le vainqueur
vous n'avez pas tout dit sur lui un type
odieux tiennent pas le mode adversaire
c'est vrai on est tous des frères mais
celui-là je suis pas le genre à porter
plainte
qu'est-ce que vous avez c'est rien j'ai
dû me le mouchoir en tombant il m'a tenu
une châtaigne dans la figure une
méchanceté
si tous les boxeurs du monde voulait se
donner la main une boutade
parce que y'a l'idéal et puis à la thur
joies du riq comme jim sur un virus y
asseoir
ça a été tellement vite je n'ai pas bien
réalisé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé je sais pas si
les gars comme moi c'est un garçon plein
de poils partout d'abord un genre
épouvantable c'est vrai on sera asie
mais que résister ici jeté sur moi
j'aurais que j'ai pas qu'ils avaient du
mal à lui je le connaissais même pas
comment je faisais un petit signe jany à
la télé vous avez la télé mais on a la
télé je la paye avec mon tempérament
oui
je veux juste à la caméra pour ma femme
pas interlude pulsions de dimanche et il
m'a tapé dans l'oeil et 10 secondes
ça passe vite quand on un sommeil parce
que la boxe s'est jamais que je le type
qui boxe pour gagner c'est plus du sport
il faut pas se prendre au jeu
moi je m'amuse c'est moche et les bras
trop petit des blagues pour boxer il
faut pas être sorti de polytechnique ya
la tête et le ventre enfin le foie
entrer dans des détails anatomiques
alors oui quand je me protège la tête
comme j'ai des boîtes ont pigé le vent
de travers mais versement j'ai plus qu'à
fermer les yeux ou alors ya les jambes
pour se replier moi et moi je tiens
c'est pas pour donner des coups de pieds
dans le jura me restait que je suis un
des plus rapides au tour de rigueur
votre défaite
j'ai jamais eu un instant sauvage je
refuse la violence
déjà quand j'étais petit mon frère me
frapper j'ai appelé ma mère alors hier
soir comme je suis ram usa crier aux puf
et au buffet des mots c'est pas mal
parce que moi j'avais la tête ailleurs
j'ai pensé à autre chose je pensais à ma
petite patricia qui vient de perdre de
temps comme son papa
loterie entendu le premier ya cru que
c'était pour lui au buffet qu'est ce qui
m'ennuie pourquoi êtes-vous devenu
boxeur au moi j'étais pas chaussé jénine
et monsieur ramirez qui m'ont poussé lui
c'est un ami nantes un ami du côté de ma
femme d'ailleurs ils sont très intime et
fois je vais au cinéma avec elle pour
pas quel sens bête
jeanine ça lui donne des migraines le
cinéma ouais c'est monsieur mieux ce qui
m'a fait découvrir le cinéma tout le
temps il m'envoie au cinéma c'est lui
qui me l'a fait découvrir ça elle est
libre je dévore simple je reste je serai
jamais qu'une brute c'est lui qui me l'a
dit je dévore littéralement teilhard de
chardin tolstoï skis duverne maxence van
der meersch des bons
j'adore ça mais la boxe c'est un sport
qui comporte bien des vicissitudes
bien sûr vous allez faire maintenant je
vais écrire un livre où je raconte des
choses de ma vie c'est pas ce qui manque
j'ai une tête comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on était un couple heureux sans histoire
placide on demandait rien à personne et
tout à coup patatrac patatrac elle
achète le journal en allant au marché
et qu'est ce qu'on apprend voilà qu'à
nouveau la princesse anne et la tête à
marc rostan l'as monaco aurait nié a
levé les yeux au ciel devant tout le
monde
quand grâce lui a pris la main la même
semaine
ça va craquer cette fois je sais que ça
va craquer fait du mal déjà la semaine
dernière on avait eu une alerte
le torchon s'était mis à brûler entre le
chat et farah diba non j'étais de rien
on était à la campagne s'inventant à
paris j'achète le journal le chat de
points at-il oublié sera ya point
d'interrogation marabout du point
d'escale
alors moi je tiens le coup je suis un
homme c'est normal je dirais vert mais
ali fallait s'y attendre
je pense qu'elle est sur dix être pareil
lui a dit merci aux français pouvait
lire je t'aime il y va parce qu'un a qui
me regardent de travers à la cour que tu
aimeras - tout le monde plusieurs
skieuses
maintenant on exige crois mais je crois
déjà comme soria s'est retrouvé sur le
carreau en exil beaufromé lola ces
foires avec park est ce qu est venu à
laon point sur toi il faut que la vitre
sur la plus forte et c'est penser autre
chose had et guy bedos et sophie daumier
qu'est ce qui s'est passé encore x et de
la part est il que c'est elle qui a un
peu trop tirer sur la ficelle et lui
fait pas il est peut être très beau
l'intérieur taïeb et leur chat soit
disant qu'ils devaient h à eybens et
elle tient à la gav et puis il prendra
pour noël et la pentecôte en face et
parler pris la place quand on pense à
toutes les misères regarde à buckingham
ça fait deux semaines que philippe a pas
adressé la parole elisabeth tl
courageuse elle rain pluie sur philippe
daydé le début je te l'avais dit je sais
pas pourquoi je me méfie de lui je peux
pas expliquer j'avais pas le contact
quand ils sont connus au début on
m'aurait demandé est ce qu elisabeth à
résoudre l'épousé juridique ils vivent
sans voix à venir
on tend lui au début il était c'est pas
grec musclé avec quelque chose de
quelque chose d'émouvant dans les yeux
la bouche ministère oui ça va ça va ça
va me faire ma petite fille on le trouve
super major question pour mon amour quoi
jackie kennedy a souri au milliardaire
paul getty la province était abondamment
jackie kennedy au lait petit petit
[Applaudissements]
bonne fête paul est venu me dire à ma
femme
bonne fête paulette et je lui donnerais
mon bouquet elle a horreur des fleurs
justement je déteste ma femme alors je
vois pas pourquoi je lui aurait offert
des chocolats
paulette adore les chocolats un mois
j'ai mon poids pour l'être alors soyons
logiques mais pourtant bien précisé à ma
mère je vais dit je veux pas épouser
paulette m'a répondu on parle pas à
table bon mon père non plus les pauvres
fous fous de ma mère mais lui trente ans
de mariage
il a fait le plus gros jeu le jour je
regarde ces gens je vis tête et bugs qui
plissent blanc aime retourne une claque
elle avait pas de base j'ai dit à ma
mère paulette est moche même répond
paulette me ressemble je dis oui mais
toi tu es ma mère elle me répond mme
paulette pourrait être ta mère bon alors
horreur des flammes à faire une de ces
tests beaucoup j'aime pas sa tête à les
mettre à la poubelle aux primes sont les
fleurs surtout les grands ne savait pas
plus de profits clécy
allez jeter c'est sûr je me refuse d
acheter avec l'argent des commissions
qui remonte mois des escalopes j'ai
horreur des escalopes se dégoûte
elles sont mais sur la vidéo elle c'est
un rêve que pour sortir au prix où sont
les escales peur c'est que leveaux s'est
pas donné un jeu la figure dans un sens
si j'avais épousé une beauté je m'ennuie
il paraît que les mannequins les
actrices c'est très ennuyeux surtout le
jour
moi j'aime bien engagé la conversation
pourleth elle parle elle dit des bêtises
beaucoup de bêtises c'est normal lorsque
les bêtes qui poussait les les filles
intellectuelle faut pas croire c'est la
barbe est sorti de l'intelligence et de
la culture
elles ont pas à grand chose peut-être
une enclume bonne fête peut l'être ça
les nerfs que je l'appelle paulette elle
poussa comment son vrai nom c'est
germaine je l'appelle paulette pour lui
rabaissé son caquet à l'agacer très cosy
ritable très soupe au lait maintenant il
n'empêche que si je m'écoutais il ya des
soirs là c'est différent
villazon lyonnaise higuain le coupé en
petits morceaux et on trouverait jamais
104 seulement ça serait dans le journal
avec sa photo alors écoutez le seul
plaisir de ma journée c'est de prendre
mon petit crème le matin tranquille à la
terrasse de chez lui
en lisant mon petit journal alors si
c'est pour retrouver la photo de
paulette en première page
bonne fête follett
[Applaudissements]
comment se comporter lorsqu'on assiste
un spectacle car sacha guitry il a dit
avant nous de même qu'il y a de bons ou
de mauvais acteurs
les spectateurs ont plus ou moins de
talent intéressé que nous sommes à
l'amélioration de l'espèce nous avons eu
l'idée de composer à l'attention de 3
public une sorte de coque du spectateur
fruit d'une déjà longue observation
d'abord l'entrée dans la salle
vous êtes en retard le spectacle est
commencée depuis 20 bonnes minutes
même si vous êtes une personnalité un
notable faites vos tout-petits écrasé
vous comme osez 4 bis quai de deux
vergers vos voisins et fatalement les
actes ça va ça va mieux on a loupé le
début
le spectacle est quelquefois dans la
salle mais celui qui est sur scène
risque parfois d'en souffrir si
décidément vous arrivez en retard ce qui
est très mal mais parfois excusable eu
égard aux difficultés de la circulation
et du parking à l'heure du théâtre que
ce soit myopie ou simplement distraction
faites tout de même attention vos posé
les pieds et le reste dans le canapé
yeux d'un spectacle comique qui
tiendrait ses promesses
laissez vous aller bien sûr riez pouffer
esclaffé vous tordez vous de bons gains
mais on évite longtemps possible de le
faire à contretemps et les réflexions du
genre pourquoi la transe
peut être que ces excès d'enthousiasmé
risque parfois de gêner l'entourent a
presque aussi gênante l'attitude
contraire qui consiste à traumatiser
littéralement tout spectateur qui
savoure oeuvrait comme il convient
lounge ouvrage représente et humour dans
la subtilité semble heureux vous
échapper elle reli kyo même je suis
désolé je suis l'auteur
dans la liste des casseurs d'ambiance le
plus redouté des côtés de la rampe
enfants en bas âge amateurs de bonbons
dans leur paquet chien dépressif et
cetera le photographe amateur ou
professionnel mérite une place de choix
tant il est vrai que la désinvolture de
son comportement et son évidente à
différence aux péripéties de la
représentation qui se déroule devant lui
fried quelquefois le sabotage
il a aussi ladom bilingue qui offre à
son compagnon étrangers et à quelques
autres une version doublée presque
simultanées cause avis tché bi tché
quelle arnaque à internet en restant à
wals à damon et on saupoudre ntv le
cognac et food and il y a le joyeux
drille le farceur de service qui
recherchent le dialogue entre la salle
et la scène est jolie et leur ai côtoyé
le
et puis il y a les silencieux qui ne
réagissent pas qui ne bronche pas qui ne
rient pas ne sourit pas ils sont
généralement placés au premier rang nous
regarde fixement avec une sorte de
rancune proche de la haine qui est
extrêmement traumatisant facile et et
darty même dans une salle de 3000
personnes chauffée à blanc nous ne
voyons plus que nous sommes fascinés par
e.on guidage demandé mais qu'est ce
qu'on leur a fait assez de là je ne
bouge pas ne bougeront pas refusant de
participer à l'euphorie générale dans un
nul qui m'apprend to man
[Applaudissements]
alors la légion étrangère tient alors
pourquoi elle sera toujours à tête
devant alain bobo oui à la papa ce cône
madame j'écoute j'écoute
ouais je voudrais parler à mes mots ces
mêmes 7e sujet bush a dit ça je vois pas
le rapport avec leur grand bleu ouais
lotois j'étais tellement bourré voilà tu
me manques tu me manques et moi c'est un
manque
ben ouais ouais mon légionnaire
on a bien violé un tu parles d'une
j'avais rien j'adore
en tout cas dit hé hé merci pour le
petit château carteau le fric que j'ai
trouvé dans my goddess merci côté toi
mais non c'est chouette si tout le monde
était comme vous ça vaudrait la peine
non mais tout de même c'est chouette ce
qui compte c'est que je puisse tentant
d'abord te dit ce qui compte c'est que
je puisse entendre par voir ses
audiences je vais pas de répéter j'ai
pas compris
l'important c'est que nous puissions
nous entendre sur les prix oui akçam
consoler un peu de pouvoir téléphoner je
te dirai ce que je pourrais pas aux
causes et l'otage est peut-être celle
occupée rattrape dans une seconde je te
prends mais simplement je voulais tu as
fait avant de partir je m'envole pour
paris dans une heure à l'avancé pour -
qui dans paris oui genre grâce à paris
c'est tout un
jeudi c'est tout ce que tu as à me dire
bah ouais
et puis merci pourquoi le ticket doux
oui tu as vu un but bah oui voir madame
ça on verra plus répond ouais c'est un
un peu de chance de soins were nous
n'étions pas destiné à nous rencontrer
marqué dans notre cas c'était plutôt le
genre brève rencontre callebaut films
téléfilms brève rencontre un radieux
rameaux à ben laden à qui elle répond
non mais moi je vous prête été
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez les mains sous les minima
elles sont chaudes c'est important les
mains la pause 13 ans
vous aviez disparu se soigner mon mari
vous l'avez bien soigné et lémance
[Musique]
j'aimerais vous et des magazines
j'allais booth vous aimez ma bouche
elle est jolie aller j'avais parce que
les crocs à la grosse louche
mon mari avait le jeu de cour ajoute
[Rires]
c'est votre première sortie on va dire
d'habitude
enfin depuis l'événement que vous savez
je vais plutôt à magath dans les squares
sur les bords de l'oise avec mon enfant
vous n'avez qu'un enfant oui
mais je souhaite en aura d'autres mais
je me dispute et souvent avec mon oeil à
ce sujet il avait la manie d'ouvrir
toutes les poneys vous aviez un grand
appartement
iman tout se fait d'être ouverte il
prétendait que c'était plus sain il
était obsédé par la maladie de quoi
est-il mort cogestion j'adorerais danser
règle d'or d'un oui c'est agréable
à ce rythme là surtout parce qu'on peut
lancer tranquillement oui mon mari
déteste et la danse il détestait ça je
parvenais quelquefois à l'entraîner dans
des endroits comme celui ci seulement
pour boire du whisky
tu étais tir et commencer à danser vous
êtes mes yeux galles signe
scorpion et vous j'aime au tabac oui
c'est intéressant
[Musique]
vous croyez à l'astrologie juge un
passionné de ça tu trouves que c'est une
science divine
les gémeaux et les scorpions se tient
terriblement ça se termine souvent très
mal j'ai déjà eu une aventure avec un
scorpion et non un désastre nous allons
nous détruire c'est probable c'est ça
vous allez des traîtres ans et je vous
le promets je sais je voudrais vous et
suffit d'essayer
nous allons nous amuser tous les deux
nous n'allons pas nous ennuyer
je me dit alain temps de briller avec ce
membre qui ne plaire
[Musique]
il
marc veille son niveau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gloria romano c'est l'inconnue la plus
célèbre du cinéma mondial
elle revient d'hollywood couverte de
lauriers de dollars avril à jean à la
sofiane à claudia voici la gloria
méchant je suis moche et de la condition
féminine je suis foutu la lumière qu'est
ce que c'est cette lumière c'est la
police ou quoi loria romain nous vous
êtes blonde jolie sensuelle 6,6 après
votre premier film américain la presse
internationale a salué en vous une
nouvelle marilyn loria romano etes-vous
marilyn monroe à ça commence voyez-vous
de la liste d'un terrible
pourquoi la marilyn toujours toujours
toujours c'est déjà douze femmes quelles
sont les marilyn dessus gloria pas nous
sommes beaucoup des blondes sur le monde
on vous a connu brume et ça change un
peu ça change un peu le pas lent c'est
la vie je peux plus me regarder avec les
événements semblait commencer dès ichi à
cet animal que vous mangez ici en france
la grenouille
oui la cades et nous non les maris le
mari et mari de la grille nous le
crapaud skds valoir décembre vous êtes
dur avec vous comparez un écrin poussée
du mal de chim et qu'est ce que c'est
alec les parlements convenable
ou par l'entité que je parle pas bien un
crapaud vous acceptez mes marilyn ça ne
semble pas vous enchanter qu on vous
compare à l annonce en tout cas ça
m'enchante pas les américaines et je
suis italienne ce ton eli lilly p'tit
pot ainsi les garder bien amusé la
maline c'était là à l'instant c'est très
sexy cette mouche ne sais pas je suis
pas un homme c'est les hommes qui
parlent toujours sexy mais vous dites
moi aussi vous accepté de tourner des
scènes très déshabillée inquiète
j'accepte aussi est si j'accepte pas je
vais tout la ville spaghettis à la
bolognaise
ah mais non le pjak oui c'est gênant
pour vous montrer tel qu'on vous a vu
dans votre dernier film pas moi qui
avais c'est ma double il démontre tout
moi pourquoi au kenya madrelle c'est pas
d'accord l idée comme ça que je suis
encore une petite bambi mais quand même
content vous déshabiller demain film
cameron est un supplice pour vous les
photos un peu aussi dans les magazines
c'est bien vous t'as pas si c'est moi
aussi je veux saluer et le photographier
à la double c'est elle qui passe
aujourd'hui à la télévision avec soit
pas moi c'est la vie c'est notre tenue
préférée pour dormir
j'ai déjà entendu ça oui moi je donne
avec un tee shirt et aussi avec le pouce
dans la bouche comme l a dit chi chi chi
mama les gentils d'une grande importance
dans votre vie a dit obsédé toi tu es
bien en france et les français sont
obsédés les italiens ils sont obsédés
les américains et sont fatigués
grand film italien en effet si vous me
fait rire
dury triste ma commune on sait très bien
qu'un homme il vaut à dimanche et nous
en italie les hommes à la la la sofia et
la pompe si monique antonioni claudio
cristallerie giulietta fellini et gloria
qui m'a le mieux l'argent on met la
donne alors dit laplante aussi une femme
gloria vous avez eu je crois une enfance
difficile
tu veux parler à l'enfance maintenant à
la coupe mathieu à nice 1 à leo amy st
[Musique]
anicette tu me souffle en fait de la
membres comptent appeler un peu les yeux
vab est à peine inférieure à gratin
ça tourne
loria vous avez eu je crois une enfance
difficile en italie
là bas les beti et demande à manger tous
les jours en italie
alors ma mère et pappa savait pas alors
moi moi attention attention vous nous
écoutez deux par deux couples magnifique
unis par l'amour réunis par le mariage
et nous vous disons bravo bravo mais
attention si l'un des deux de tout à
coup se séparer de l'eau faire commander
sa petite valise
il doit au moins sacrifier la politesse
du coeur par exemple on ne doit pas
annoncer la chose comme ceci
une petite devinette qui est ce qu il ya
de gens bien nés cinq enfants qui va se
retrouver sur le carreau s'il est ou non
ça ça n'est pas bien il faut prendre des
formes c'est la moindre des choses nous
déconseillons franchement les raccourcis
du genre mais le shérif qui se taisent
de peur et me dit qu'il veut pas être
lue par un pass non non ça n'est pas
d'hypocrisie non plus pas de numéro dans
ce style tu sais la grande asperge la
cie la blonde vulg à sélectionner énorme
ouais la grande idiote et ben je pars
avec elle mais je peux te dire que ça
m'amuse pas un fou
dit les choses avec simplicité
n'attendez pas de saisir la balle au
bond si votre mari vous dis qu'est ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui simone ne vous
jetez pas sur l'occasion pour répondre
c'est pas son divorce et rappelons nous
par ailleurs que l'amour n'est pas un
jeu de hasard
il est mal élevé de faire ceci attention
les yeux puis le jaune est fait je m'en
vais et puis on recommence pas ce manque
de bol c'est lui ginette et sans rancune
non ça n'est pas bien de même si vous
partez très bien parti mais en douceur
sans commentaire c'est vrai abstenez
vous des critiques en plus ne dit pas
quoi tu es la vie devant toi t'as 56
sentais pas marrante mais t'es gentil
liste dans les 400 francs par mois et tu
pleurniche elle manque d'humour et
fatigués les choses comme elles sont
avec coeur avec générosité dit si ça ne
va pas le sien parlons presque chisson
ouvrons-nous lucien mais ne dit pas mal
honnêtement écoute ses parents nous une
vingtaine d'années après ça on y verra
plus clair d'accord 1 il n'est pas cela
veut des choses simples ils vont
pourtant mieux dire ce que l'on a dit
plutôt que de le chanter par exemple on
faire comprendre la situation à l'autre
avec un mauvais goût dans le genre
dans cette odieuse
c'est odieux c'est infect mieux vous
dire carrément c'est la fin mood cdu
c'est dur mais c'est moins dur que
d'entendre dans le genre sado
masochistes ce qui me plaît tout
directement mais sa taille sa grosse
bouche à ses grosses mains des salvages
team juin
fous l'camp fous l'camp c'était dans la
peau les divines toi et quand enfin le
grand jour sera d'arriver le grand jour
du départ soyez ému soyez inoubliable
partait avec élégant lit par exemple au
revoir et peut-être demain
marie madeleine mais n'évitent tient à
l'acte et de bouma grande que aider à
porter milanais jusqu'au taxi enfin le
temps se chargera peut-être de remplacer
l'amour par les différents alors le
bousculer par la chose ne dit pas en
partant aller voir chez madame et merci
pour tous la cuisine est foutue dire les
enfants c'était du tonnerre au revoir
rappelez vous
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà c'est fini c'est fini
des chouettes trop le web on va chialer
ben saïda chiale ah ben c'est plus fort
que moi de me faire ma chaque fois
sensiblerie on est des hommes et toi
ouais
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
et voilà qu les plus chéris rouge va
tomber sur les modestes marionnettes que
nous sommes on va atteindre une à une
toutes ces lumières sur les cales comme
des papillons nous étions tenus ou
brûlés nous allons remonter dans notre
petite cloche insalubre et on va faire
les comptes
on n'a pas eu de l'obtenir sur la brute
il aurait même les taxes les droits
d'auteur et on rester porte sur bordeaux
les frais de publicité conflit de
service je sais plus quoi encore ces
véhicules à être là
[Musique]
c'est toujours c'est ça qui compte le
public où qu'ils soient là n'y a que ça
qui compte
[Applaudissements]
voilà où est ce qui t mes copains plein
combat 400 m plat à bureaux fermés on
sait bien ensemble oui alors qu est ce
qu on a rigolé on a du mérite parce que
vraiment la vie c'est payet c'est
dégueulasse de la société de merde
le fric le fric le fric et nous on est
pareil
rires plus pire est devenu 10e une
dizaine
mais tellement de bien de temps en temps
de faire son autocritique je vais rester
alia les soirs dès ce soir justement pas
ce soir soit à vous comme sa vie soit on
les voit pas mais certains soirs dans
certains endroits
si on était un panneau entrée interdite
aujourd'hui ça se bousculait pas la
caisse ça qu'on ne met pas
oh
l'entente de joie il peut jouer à tous
crever à gauche entre la bombe les
accidents de la route même maladie la
pollution on a pour et c'est dans tous
les journaux
aux dernières nouvelles ce scélérat
ouais c'est ouf mais moi j'ai pas
évident non plus dans moi on n'a aucune
chance de s'en tirer
[Applaudissements]
m
à
elle a bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce soir c'est moi le numéro un je suis
là veulent est numéro 1 il ya toute la
france qui me regardent bonsoir la
france ça va vous moi ça va c'est dur en
ce moment ça va aller ça on vous l'a dit
à la publicité
en france on n'a pas de pétrole mais on
a des idées ça ira ça ira ça ira je me
disais un indice taiex bien connu à son
chauffeur ou non est urgent et une
augmentation
croyez-moi lucien c'est pas nous les
plus à plaindre il pas nous c'est pas
nous ah lalala lalala tous ces pays qui
crèvent de faim c'est pas du possible
c'est pas possible ça pète et péter de
partout
les chinois les indiens les africains
nous venions goisses le chinois etc + 1
chez les merengues
j'en sais plus rien tout ça c'est paris
et après le journal télé j'ai été saisi
d'un bourg d'où des passeurs j'ai bien
vu le mourousi il a eu une petite mine
voilà des millions de gens qui crèvent
de faim je me suis je peux pas rester
immobile devant ce spectacle
il faut que je fasse quelque chose il
faut faire je suis allé au restaurant
monsif occupe malade j'ai commencé par
une soupe de courge
après on a eu une petite terrine à base
de têtes de veau mélangé avec du pied de
cochon très fin du gras double j'en ai
repris deux fois le tout arrosé d'un
sauternes un peu d'où un peu trop de
boue mais enfin les temps sont durs
voilà fait pas la peine de faire du
scandale alors qu'au bangladesh
j'ai enchaîné avec une cassolette de
queues d'écrevisses au lard ça c'était
les entrées comme viande
j'ai hésité entre une mois braisé au
centre canard et un porcelet à la gelée
de groseille le maître d'hôtel m'a dit
et j'ai eu deux les deux ou six prix des
plats comme chez nous
[Rires]
mais pour vous et alors le plateau de
fromages de szczesny stop ça suffit
je me réserve pour le dessert on va
présenter la honte des desserts jamais
un tel cas phare que je me suis tapé de
tous maintenant je suis me jusque là
j'ai dit au maître d'hôtel arrêté comme
on dit vulgairement j'ai les dents du
fond qui baigne d'ailleurs à la fin ça
n'a pas loupé j'ai tout mon ouïe la
contrariété
[Applaudissements]
je suis méchant moi je méchant je
méchant garçon
le docteur m'a dit qu'elle ait eu à j'ai
40 ans rom et huyghe rang
oui je suis grand je bave et siebel
j'aime pas les petites filles j'ai dit
est la petite fille le père noël
n'existe pas docteur macondé tu n'aimes
pas cette petite fille entends-tu et son
papa oui je suis son papa qu'est ce qui
est arrivé
pourtant que était à l'école oui école
nationale d'administration ena et tu te
souviens de ce qu'on a appris et non
[Applaudissements]
tu joues bien de récents sont réunis
chanson que tu chantais la situation
économique dans l'industrie nationale
est préoccupant j'aime pas juste car je
ne partirai que j'aime papunya j'ai pas
trop le docteur me dit chers amis c'est
de la régression infantile et gratiot
infantile le jeu par odile je pars sans
me retourner non pas poil au nez
neut esclaves pas jeu par odile tu
prouves et bien pouf
tu ne me crois pas mais je m'en vais
comme dit si bien verlaine au vent
mauvais plait-il odile lesquels
explications il n'y a rien
d'extraordinaire
j'ai besoin de son souffle rauque sur ma
nuque embrasé penthalaz nombre j'ai
besoin de ses mains à la recherche de
sonorités nouvelles sur le clavier de
mais sans se dire j'y pensais encore ce
matin mon bureau crédit lyonnais
tout ce que je demande c'est de courir
nu sous une pluie fine sur la falaise
avec des grands chais mouillé c'est pas
par simple réponse à bateaux rien dans
un champ de blé mûr avec un air de
vivaldi qui nous tourner la tête
qu'est ce que tu veux que je te dise non
je ne renie pas le passé mais l'avenir
dit il c'est sa jambe gauche quand elles
passent derrière mon dos pour qui on
earth elle touche mon oreille pendant à
droite qu'on ne change nous et vient
s'enrouler autour de ce volet est ce
qu'il faut te faire un dessin à od il
ah ça y est le bureau des pleurs
maintenant mais il ne s'agit pas de
savoir si ça bouge en brasse
techniquement mieux
- bien que la tienne bon ses pieds sont
plus grands et alors ce n'est pas un
concours c'est une histoire comme il y
en a tous les jours je laime c'est tout
c'est classique et lui aussi il même
c'est la vie ça s qui était anodine
[Applaudissements]
si un truc qui vaut mieux éviter
si on veut pas tomber malade c'est de
compulser un dictionnaire médical parce
que là si vous êtes tant soit peu
impressionnable cité un tout petit peu
émotif toi ce que tu lis tu la vois des
postes est pas moins c'était pour ma
fille est la cadette le lot qui nous
attraper des boutons et oui on n'a qu'à
nous fait des boutons le lot et quand je
dis bouton je pense plutôt du bon c'est
même le groupe du bon si c'est un fruit
ça serait plus prix de la cerise que la
myrtille tu vois courir email sellal a
pas de pot enfin si mais dylan déjà que
bon c'est ma fille mes objectifs doit
quand même pop cocotte pub le lot on
peut pas dire qu'elle soit vraiment nom
est sympathique et attachante mais alors
là ça lui fait des joues de tranches de
tête est gratos ans c'est dégueulasse
allez brandir de chouettes beau
vachement appétissant alors on est allé
voir un dermatologue
il a reçu culte et de partout passe en
temps j'ai détourné il a dégoupillé
dessus ils sont comme tous les teams ça
vaut la peine de faire des études
enfin il a regardé quand même ce qui
déjà sympa de sa part et aux résultats
et ben il sait pas voilà il voit pas
bien il faut que je réfléchisse sur la
docteure merci beaucoup comme je vous
dois voyez mon assistante 20 sacs 10
dont il y en a qui veulent pas leur
pognon enfin on sait tous que c'est pas
c'est pas le choses à risque où je bois
je serai jamais le dire c'est pas à
l'hérésie ped ça on est sûr c'est pas
les rites m parce que l'érythème c'est
plutôt fessiers et à la par tous est
dégoûtante
ce n'est pas non plus une quelconque
mycoses nico heynckes ça serait
peut-être sans engagement d'aucune par
une kératoses pilaire virulente
bini voilà on est content alors j'ai
regardé dans le dico cas kératoses
affection bénigne en effet se présente
en plus comme un état de la peau qu une
maladie à part entière c'est pas une
maladie c'est pour ça que ça soit une
transmission héréditaire héréditaire
probable rencontrer dès l'enfance
ça c'est sa mère qui lui a refilé chez
nous dans ma famille kératoses on n'a
pas ça nous j'ai demandé à tout le monde
à mes parents mon pépé à main lui on n'a
pas c'est pas nous
bien deux c'est peu ça ceux des glaces
évolution des buts le plus souvent dans
l'enfance
oui et peut subir une accentuation des
signes lors de la puberté
là elle est encore petit yacht mais
avait tested le vote jeune fille vient
nous aider à lui trouver un fiancé ça on
pourra toujours mettre une annonce dans
des stations thermales y aura bien un
eczéma de passage qui sera intéressé à
cet âge là c'est bien connu ça les
démange les petits bourgs à la vache
chez la femme
fréquence une guérison spontanée à l'âge
mûr
on vient de fêter ses cinq ans en avril
dernier à se gratter la couenne jusqu'à
sa ménopause
c'est les 40 premières années qui sont
les plus durs d'ici là pour son
anniversaire au lieu des moufles ils ont
rien prévu sur l'euthanasie
à ce jeu les missions bien dans ces
missionnaires vachement encourageant
rassurant bien moi quand je dis ça j'ai
tout et puis on écoute du tas de trucs
la langue noir or ce n'est pas une
définition hypertrophie des papilles
filiforme de la partie postérieure de la
langue celle ci devienne grises ou
noires at à la vache on est peu de chose
réfection indolore ah ben ça fait
origine inconnue il dans les titres et
ils se relayent matin il a la langue
noir personne ne sait d'où ça vient pour
peu qu'ils soient catholiques
pratiquants et la commune passe pas
inaperçu le mec
on agissait la communion c'est plus que
maman t'as plus besoin de montrer train
le curé authentiques signés en tout le
groupe dans un coin en passant encore de
dieu autant aller à la boulangerie
tonnes chose rare du pain frais
même la maison du conte que le rideau
tombé sur un compte venir marquer que tu
as du noir sur la norme
[Musique]
la langue noah à la vache si je me
doutais que ça existait des machins
pareil alors traitement de points ok
mais comme ça moi c'était ça c'est pour
le type ia rien ne disait pas tout ça
lui vient les apports pas au nettoyage
du lent allô docteur g à l'invs noir et
ben monsieur c'est votre problème
les goûts et les couleurs moi je suis
marié avec une japonaise et j'en fais
également go noir désaxé rien parce
qu'on peut toujours su séduisant pour
donner le change mais il ya des trucs
dans ce bouquin cumin testiculaire ça
c'est pas mal non plus s'observe à tout
âge les formes maligne surpoids
féminisant tu es peuvent donner des
tests biologiques de la grossesse
positif dire que ce coup là le type non
seulement ils sont tous les deux les
baloches comme des paupiettes mais en
plus je relance filet en cloque j'espère
qu'on lui fait l'accouchement sans
douleur au tiff jusqu'au maintenant
c'est à dire les marges mon chapeau
comme ça ils vont rattraper aux
relations je me mets à courir partout
dans les couleurs de l'hosto en passant
je pratique encore avec une plume dans
le cul ah bah moi ça plus comment gueule
métier à l'horreur mais quelle horreur
mais comment il faut tous ces médecins
pour supporter tout ça tous les jours ça
je me le demande souvent parce que si
c'est dans le livre il est gros il ya
planète comme ça et c'est fait par des
gens qui savent donc ça arrive dans la
vie tous les jours comment ils font faut
voir moral surtout dans certains
secteurs
le type qui se spécialise dans une
maladie qui se guérit pas
demain
le moral
moi je pourrais pas ici là je fait
l'intéressant je raconte mon
dictionnaire médical mais j'ai horreur
de ce genre décoration horaires horreur
parce que il faut que je vous fasse un
aveu mois rien que d'en parler
la maladie ça me tue salut je suis
content j'ai décroché la faire enfin
quand je dis je j'exagère
mon agence de publicité publique
pour us tue c'est nous qui avons lancé
les semelles cryptex et l'année d'après
et les caps mais l'ex menace sur ce
coup-ci attention on n'était pas tout
seul vous coincez dit une campagne
électorale
y aller tout le monde ils étaient tous
il y avait havas et publicis
il y avait l'autre là qui a fait la
campagne de mitterrand
je vais pas dire son nom parce que je
n'ai pas à faire de la réclame à la
concurrence résultat des courses c'est
moi qui ai décroché à tes balles
allaient rouler alors le crédit d'un
sauna je peux pas vous le dire parce que
justement première chose je vais le
faire changer de mains ils trop marqué
depuis 25 ans il est passé de gauche à
droite de droite à gauche au centre à
droite à gauche
c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas des bandes
documents sur lui sur toutes les photos
il bouge mon idée très branché très
ouais c'est d'essayer de trouver un nom
et si les familles sans se décident
racheter un an oui
achetez pas trouvé racheté pendant que
marie christine barrault aurait pété là
moi j'étais dans la coulisse attend que
ce soit mon tour mais j'appelle c'est
complètement moi je tiens tout ça allawi
du coup il allume la lumière la base
j'arrête mon sketch vous allume la
lumière à lyon c'est fini en coupe ont
atteint et c'est ça la vie oui j'ai eu
un trou de mémoire quoi et alors on
étale intelligent et julien tomas
et
mon idée très branché très beau et c'est
d'essayer de racheter un nom oui si les
familles sont d'accord dont le
propriétaire d'origine et moi mais dans
le nom garde encore un crédit énorme sur
le puits voyez laval
blum
franco quelque chose comme ça vous
achetez de la fine napoléon
l'argent ne va plus dans la poche de
napoléon c'est un noir pdg qui a repris
le nom
et quand un homme merveilleux comme
monsieur paul ricard va passer la main
ce sera pluies mais son nom servira de
caution pour ben hur et des générations
et des générations et enfin en attendant
il ya du travail vient du travail le
regard à télévision on change rien
comme il me dit vous emportez votre
pragmatisme je vous apporte mon
strabisme la face au fond des yeux ça
n'a pas marché lui la regarde un contenu
au sud-ouest aux morts le temps des
travaux très bien rien dire mais son
élocution il au vote n'est pas comme ça
qu'on a toujours réglé je suis gêné mais
toyota devant 2000 personnes là lui sont
des scissions au sein de l'opposition
une position qui n'ont pas fait ma
saucisse
arrête je meurs je vais jeter toutes les
dents comme je vais mettre que des dents
en ordre pour rassurer les épargnants
sans inquiéter les riches j'ai demandé
aussi de changer de femme il veut pas
elle m'énerve elle elle m'énerve elle
consomme ni elle dit alors tu as ton
recevra la visite de monsieur ronald
reagan
je lui ferai une quiche maalot à la
grenobloise qu'est ce que je pourrais
lui faire dire sur les habits et la
coiffure je la ridiculise schlingue
groth et ce qu'ils veulent un carnaval
is je vais changer la couleur de ses
cheveux nattés d'une couleur je vous dis
pas c'est patati sait comment sous les
affiches réponse absente
parce que m'ont dit les affiches s'est
isolé un village typiquement français le
ciel derrière et de 20 au premier plat
personnes n'ont rebondi et à la place on
écrit en grosses lettres majuscules lui
il est déjà au travail
ange vert au président quand même qu est
ce qu on dit dans les slogans que vous
êtes de gauche de droite puisque gilles
guimond fille m'excuse roland si je le
dis je faire automatiquement 50% des
voix un tas sur le professionnel rom et
les peace and we will be c'est là que
franchement j'étais génial d'ailleurs il
m'a téléphoné après il m'a dit
heureusement je vous embrasse
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir remarquer
que la droite dit partout que la gauche
accumule les maladresses
je vous dit rien vous allez en termes de
ce programme à partir de lundi surtout
des radios c'est sa voix à le liquide y
voter pour moi pour une gauche à droite
[Applaudissements]
cet après midi j'étais à l' usine mon
usine
j'ai regardé la france à travers la
vitre savez ce genre de vitres là je
peux comment ça s'appelle en sécurité
pour pâques un imbécile
il me balancer un boulon dedans il me la
[ __ ] en l'air
j'étais encore sous le choc
une scène très pénible avec les délégués
syndicaux
je leur ai dit vous les clefs vous les
voulez mais voilà mais si j'avais pas
dit poisson d'avril au dernier moment
inexpliqué mon frère est entré avec son
beau visage buriné par le farniente
jeudi commence à dater yeux parce qu'il
s'était fait des ampoules aux paupières
à force de dormir
regardez tous les deux la foule des
ouvriers qui s'écoulait de la sortie 830
personnes quand même plus 80 noir
et 120 femmes
au total un millier de personnes un
millier de salaire je sentais son odeur
de vétiver derrière moi il me dit de
savoir caverneuse bientôt plus personne
n'aura plus rien plus un lyon plus un
club de golf plus un van gogh ryan ou
lamento france où nous mène-t-il pour
moi j'ai mon dossier des impôts là on me
reproche mais chevaux de course mais je
suis navré un cheval de course
saab est moins qu'une secrétaire et nous
en parlions avec les autres l'affiché de
l'encouragement de la race chevaline
mais la race chevaline elle va
décourager mon yacht mon yacht 40 mètres
de long
quatre moteurs six marins vous passez
l'urssaf
mais vous savez ce qu'on fait avec mon
yacht on longe le bord du port de cannes
parce que mon épouse meneur de peur que
par une femme malade
le climat social lui donne de l'asthme
son seul dérivatif cdh rajeunir de
secret mme nuit et jour moralité en
trois ans et l'a rajeunie d'une heure
on longe le bord ont fait des huit à
l'intérieur du port et on revient au
mouillage mais s'appuie stick qui ont
gènes qui ont gêne comme fois que
j'entends ça pour quoi vous servez vous
d'un avion privé
parce que johnny attendant on avion s
ils me prennent dessus je mens pas non
non
j'étais obligé de dire à mon personnel
je ne peux pas vous garder je ne peux
pas à la campagne on avait une paire
d'émigrer enfin paris qui va aujourd'hui
un couple d'émigrés aux immigrés or là
je sais pas comment il faut dire façon
comme dit mon épouse on sait pas où ils
vont d'où ils viennent alors
immigrés émigrés servions même tahrir
même au demeurant des gens discrets ils
ont accepté un salaire pour deux ailes
elle tient la maison elle fait la
cuisine lui il est logé dans son lit et
en échangeant lui demande de l'aider un
peu au jardinage à la maçonnerie à
l'entretien de la ferme
au gardiennage de nuit il conduit la
voiture
il a réparé quand elle est en panne
on a trois rugissants occupent ils
coupent les arbres
bon je leur fais une salle de bain
qu'est ce qu'ils me foutent de d'un du
charbon ma mère est prévenu et en plus
c'est moi qui peut faire grimper par
l'inspection du travail
où voulez vous qui m est charmant
puisque vers la salle de bains de la cad
c'est pas la cerise sur le gâteau ça
c'est pas la cerise sur le gâteau
attendant la maison car perdre oui elle
estime fans dessus je mens pas mais bon
classe et tous les sans emploi je crée
votre jour un de mes livres y y et diane
de villandry se prend une épine dans une
pâte
voilà 180 heures à ferrari pour foncer
chez le vétérinaire au croisement je
mens personnes tracteur ben j'ai
continué j'avais rien rien j'avais quand
même mon aileron arrière droit
spécialement car aussi en italie par le
couturier giovanni tortelli qui carrosse
mais voiture et ma femme ne l'ont
arraché ça tout le monde s'en fout mais
derrière moi le paysan bassin fracturé
gendarmerie ambulanciers brancardier
deux motards pourrir le chemin ils
croisent les pompiers parce que le
tracteur s'était inversée incendies dans
les cultures
affolement à l'hôpital mais
saperlipopette je vais travailler toute
une région
je fais travailler toute une région
alors le 1 % voient la sécurité sociale
par exemple je suis allé voir mon
contrôleur des contributions et je dis
simplement combien gagnez vous combien
gagnez-vous il répond temps je lui dis
eh bien le 1 % comme le réclame sur mon
revenu représente cette fois votre
salaire
il est resté de marbre alors j'étais
obligé de dire la femme jeune et peu
plus de garder je ne peux plus
l'état me prends tous qu ils te prennent
aussi qui se chargent de toi ma poule
jeu de nationalise non partir changer
d'horizon demain de coutume de racine
partir loin
g
pour se faire naturaliser il faut
remplir un formulaire
1 pour quel pays optez vous deux pour
quelles raisons
alors j'ai rempli et j'attends un monaco
2 pour l'avion a le foot le foot le foot
le foot le foot le foot y'a plus que ça
le foot le foot le foot le foot le foot
la france est foutue et moi c'est le
bouquet je vis avec un footballeur et en
plus il joue gaulle alors ces chartes
pour les rapports lavage les tâches des
rebonds jours c'est ce qu'il ya de pire
avec la phrase et la pêche
surtout il se dit cependant qu'il a le
dos tourné ils trient cabot il plonge
pour un oui pour un non
ça m'empêche pas de l'aimer même sur des
petites choses oui jb histoire ramasse
les crottes et t shirt la galerie non il
faut qu'il plonge et mois après comme
dit ma drogue l'istis quoi fine essayé
avec homo le flouze l'ambiance à la
maison avant les matchs dans l'une fait
les sautes cas moi je ne moufte pas le
tenue avant la coupe d'europe ils savent
bien sûr je sers dans mes bras il
tremblait 1 m 89 quand même enfin ils me
disent des blousons table je viens de
faire un rêve dans lequel j'étais une
passoire
j écoute bambi qui a été sélectionné
scolaire vionnet international militaire
tu vas pas nous faire des convulsions
pour ces bâches
hindi lève toi et tes mois les penaltys
finidi george pâte à bolt a vu leur
d'abord les citoyens les penaltys nous
voilà dans notre idylle premier tir je
le prend à contre pied sans le vouloir
bien sûr au processus m'en fous il
détourne du point je reprend de la tête
but
ne craignez pas tu m'a bousculé moi
c'est musclé mois-ci bousculer notre
chien chez ma chère vous moi c'est
bousculer zee carton rose carton rouge
qu'il y ait ou peut être un juge unique
comment tu peux être un juge comme ça
bonsoir monsieur henri michel qui est
dit mais vous savez le successeur de
michel hidalgo monsieur michel traîne
enfin j'aime beaucoup son look blond les
jaunards y est ré sais pas si vous
rappelez georges descrières sociétaire
de la comédie française
bref savez fédérer à l'estragon des
petits rideaux vénitienne avec un
dégradé de projets temps mais jamais bon
bambi se servent et je vois bien mon
henri michel des petites rien de plus
ipic de sardan louis avec ta béchamel
des yeux d'une méchanceté à l'état
béchamel ta couche de toi je dirais
jamais la cage longe de france alors moi
je reconnais je suis impulsif je dis
c'est peut-être pas à cause de ma
béchamel une jackie chan c'est peut-être
pas à cause d'eux avait chamelle c'est
peut-être parce qu'ils prennent pas les
passoires
et je bouffe qu'est ce que j'avais pas
fais push et il me dit écoute berthe
je m'appelle bertrand et cloud berthe
quand un couple en arrive à se dire ces
choses là à se déchirer comme ça il vaut
mieux se séparer transfert mois et tout
à coup il lui a transmis à notre siège
machine
magic le drame n'est pas que chez nous
je vois dans son équipe
je peux pas dire les noms mais bon le 2
et avec le 5 le 6 et le 7 malgré la
différence d'âge sont ensemble depuis
des gens très gentils très potes sont
connus à l'ogcnice ensuite ils ont muté
pour le fc grenoble maintenant ils sont
ici cantona qui dribble l'autre est
derrière un couple sans histoire j'en
dirai pas autant du 8 et du rose du
moins depuis que le président a acheté
ce noir d'une beauté et d'une beauté
l'audio comme toujours je vais leur dire
bonjour je vais serrer quelques mains
sous les douches les abdominaux et
dorsaux de saioua total mardi soir 33e
minute du match contre nancy super
laissant du onze qui vous déborde toute
la défense adverse et les huit il est
marqué dans les buts tout seul alors
plus de ce qu'ils mangent pas je n'avale
pas et lui je leur ai toujours le pied
sur le ballon
eh bien non qu'ils me rendent d'abord
aux cocos nous qui me rend d'abord au
caucus en le foot et c'est pas le tout
bambi qu'est ce que je veux en faire moi
quand il va être la retraite à 31 ans
comme je dis amis oui ce penseur non
tunique rhésus ni bernard tapie tac
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]